hey everybody and welcome to
a major rock star episode of wild ride
with stevo
man this is exciting dude slipknot one
of the biggest
metal acts on the planet ever and
they've just been going stronger and
stronger like
for what over 20 years dude
man get ready because this is rock and
roll
ladies and gentlemen corey taylor
yeah dude so i would like you to meet my
co-host
scott randolph hey corey hello dude how
are you
and up at the front of the van we've got
the gorgeous paul briskey
hey corey how are you i agree with the
the gorgeous nice oh wow
dude that's [ __ ] up and his voice oh
my god
deep voice big balls
there you go it's a pleasure to talk to
you thanks man
yeah man i mean [ __ ] dude i gotta uh
plead ignorance man i i couldn't i
wasn't ready for when you were on the
bert cast
like that you've got the biggest numbers
the bert cast
ever had bird of course being bert
kreischer and yeah
yeah and bert's got the biggest numbers
we've ever done on this podcast
i mean hey the ripple effect of bert and
i was with them
just earlier today i was i co-hosted uh
two bears in one cave
oh [ __ ] that's i love that show too man
like
i'm like a big podcast guy so i love all
that [ __ ]
uh well [ __ ] right on man and uh
thanks for doing this it's great to have
you
first question is uh [ __ ] how old are
you dude you look like
you're [ __ ] early 20s
[Laughter]
i don't know how much money i owe you
for that but that's [ __ ] rad man i
i'm 47. holy [ __ ] dude
i'm 46.46 and i was thinking too because
i you know i watched a number of youtube
videos to prepare for this and
and uh it i was just struck thinking man
like
is this like an old ass video because
you look so young
and then that like now here you are
[ __ ] color
like that the hat isn't like a disguise
hair loss or anything now
i you know honestly i'm wearing the hat
because it's like
bed head day you know how it is like the
quarantine bought out all the laundry
looks
you know it's it's pretty funny why i
get it man
and then you know like i'm sure that
with the questions and the masks and
slipknot none of the masks is probably
[ __ ] uh you know ad nauseam uh
tiresome but my i just think get a
little bit of a pisser to wear a mask
when you're so goddamn good looking
right you know the funny thing is i in
2004 i was voted
hottest dude and heavy metal in the mask
which i i don't know i don't know if
that's a good
or bad thing but i just i've always held
on to that it's like i was number four
you know in the mask and i've never
charted without it so there you go
were they clear in making the
distinction that it was with the mask on
or did they
oh yeah yeah no it was a picture of me
in the mask they didn't include
any of my masks
i'm way hotter in a mask i promise i
swear to god
i don't know that i agree with that
have you always been or have you ever
been
like really uh guarded protected about
what your true identity is
like you won't appear without damascus
well i mean we were
we were in the beginning you know in the
beginning
it was it was it was cool that nobody
really knew who we were
you know and the reason that we wore the
masks
wasn't for anonymity or anything really
like that it was
it was all part of this this artistic
vision that we had
you know and part of it was the shock
value but at the same time
it lent itself to the artistic stylings
that we were trying to
to kind of go for like it was almost
like a uniform like we were
we were the anti-image you know like
at the time everybody was so shiny and
pretty
and everybody had their fashion and
whatnot and here we were
nine dicks from iowa and we were like
you know what you don't get our
cheekbones or our hairstyle here's our
mask
you don't get our fashion here's our
coveralls you don't get our name here's
our name
our number here's our bar code it was
basically almost like an
anti-establishment thing
yeah but by anti-establishment you mean
specifically anti-industry
right like yeah guys very much so yeah
you guys operated within the music
industry and
vocally and like energetically opposing
the very industry you were in right
right yeah we tried to eat it
and uh we actually threw it back up so
i'm not sure if that was a good thing or
a bad thing
but there you have it right i almost i
was trying to figure it out like how
many [ __ ] masks have there been cause
you changed your mouth is it every album
is a different mask
i changed my album uh my mask every
album yeah some guys
like what they what they wear so they
change it like subtly
right i like to evolve mine
yeah clowns well clowns is i mean he's
still the clown
but his changes every album like
it's still a clown mask but it's totally
different yeah yeah the first one was
very
like almost happy clown and then the
second one was dark as [ __ ] with the
pentagram and [ __ ]
right right right the the cool thing
about the original clown mask was that
was his original mask from when he was i
want to say like 12 years old
oh wow yeah yeah so he keeps that one
protected he still has it
and every once in a while he'll bring it
out just to like [ __ ] with us
to be honest and it's just like oh god
you know that's great man the uh that's
like my cheetah there's only ever been
one cheetah print bikini
right yeah exactly everybody's got that
one thing that like that's the original
and that's you know there's you can have
you know imitations whatever but it's
not the same man like you can
carry it through the years so what was
he doing with that mask when he was 12.
was it like for halloween or
it was just like wow
he was running around the neighborhood
dude he was a maniac like he
hit the reason and this actually
predates me being in the band
the reason that they started wearing
masks in the first place is because he
started wearing his mask at
practice man like they would be in the
basement like they weren't even in front
of anybody man he would just
he would put that on and it would just
bring
a different type of energy out of his
playing and
what he was doing so slowly but surely
everybody in the band started bringing
their own masks
to practice like they didn't even debut
this look until after they had really
kind of consolidated it
and then when i joined they actually
helped me kind of put together my first
mask
and it was it was crazy man it was like
it was a really cool vibe
you know just it allows you to just go
somewhere really gnarly and yet
still be connected with the audience and
connected with the music and
but he's just yeah he's just he's just
different cat man
yeah i mean when you put the mask on are
you corey taylor or you just somebody
else completely on stage
it's a little bit of it's it's it's a
little bit of
certain aspects of me you know because i
mean nobody is
is one-sided you know everybody's very
multi-level like multi-layered
we all have like different dimensions to
us and
that mask and that music represents a
certain side of me certain events
in my life certain things that i've gone
through certain things i fight
to this day you know and when i take it
off i can kind of come back and
be a well-rounded cory as opposed to
just this
you know nightmarish guy but it's it's
definitely a part of me it's not all who
i
am but it's definitely a part of who i
am you know right yeah it was
interesting uh
uh when people say you know they have a
really good personality or this person
the the root word of personality is
persona and persona comes from the greek
uh mask so i when somebody has a good
personality i just feel like they're
just it's a good mass that they're
wearing for that time and
it's not really where they are you know
if somebody's real charismatic it's
probably they're hiding something
wow [ __ ] scott randolph coming in
deep what happened
now before you joined slipknot i i i
found this particularly
[ __ ] fascinating that uh
the first incarnation of slipknot
without having a record deal
went into the studio to record a demo
and that demo
like they spent 40 [ __ ] thousand
dollars to make a demo
not even an album and like it just seems
like it speaks to like
how much the landscape of music has
changed
where now all it takes is like a [ __ ]
iphone
you know like oh yeah well a couple
plugins yeah it's
it's crazy right like right but that was
different times man i mean
even the i mean when we started
pro tools was still like this
thing that nobody could really
understand you know our first
three out my my first three albums were
all done on two inch tape
man so it took forever so you had to
like if you were an engineer or a
producer you had to know your way around
these technologies now any
dick with a pro tools rig can call
himself a producer you know
like you got the right plugins you can
create something
that either sounds exactly like
everything else that's on the radio
or masks all the
the the hidden uh deficiencies all right
that's me being very political right now
so do you think do you see that as a
good thing or a bad
thing that it's like equal opportunity
for everybody to express their musical
you know [ __ ] art or
do you think [ __ ] man it's all these
[ __ ] coming in that shouldn't be
making music
well i have various uh
depends on what day you ask them no no
i'm pretty i'm pretty consistent
i on the one hand i love
how fast the technology is because it
means people like myself
who like to work fast we can get a lot
of good [ __ ] done
quick we don't waste our time trying to
figure out a way to kind of trick
the technology to do more than it's
actually doing
so it allows people like me people like
who are
in my position to be able to work quick
especially when it comes to demos
you know demos used to take forever and
now
i can go in and i can track six songs in
a day
you know and just and get it done
because the technology can keep up with
my brain
now the the flip side of that is that
there's there's two sides to the coin
one it means that everyone can
sound good but it doesn't necessarily
mean that they are
good does that mean that makes sense
like
you can you can it's the old adage you
can polish a turd
it's still a piece of [ __ ] you know like
for me
evening the playing field has made it
harder
for lazy people to discern
what is good and what is bad because
the crowd like like the audience for the
most part
aren't as educated as far as like you
know like
a lot of people who listen to my music
don't have the
the musical background that i do of like
delving into
genres and artists and bands like really
going deep in and learning the history
of
what the stuff that i love you know most
people are like oh it's top 40 that's
just what i'm gonna do you know right so
anything that sounds like that
they're gonna just they're like okay
that's good that's it may not
but it's made it very easy for people to
slide under the radar
you know now it's not up to me to
to say what's popular and what's not
that's obviously
you know the audience that's the mass
but
that means i don't listen to a lot of
current music
sure yeah neither do i when people have
ever asked me
what kind of music do you like i've
always kind of bristled out the question
and my response
like sort of snarky like you know what
like i consider music like
food and i don't always want to eat
[ __ ] twinkies
you know i wouldn't [ __ ] change it up
like you know and
yeah absolutely and then i take it a
step further
and i say i don't even think that the
people have necessarily
musical tastes they've got more musical
associations and by that i mean
you could listen to almost anything and
through repetition through repetition
you're gonna
develop a relationship with that music
you almost like
it's almost like your life experience
becomes fused with music so that when
you hear a certain track later on in
life it brings you back to that those
emotions those feelings those times
so like you know we become associated
with music
and i think you listen to anything
enough you're gonna fall in love with it
and that's why
the music industry is so successful at
just ramming [ __ ] down your throat
and then that's what you want you know
um yeah
i always say what genre's audio books
because that's my favorite type of music
i guess that would be that'd be spoken
word i guess right yeah yeah
now you recorded your first slipknot
album when you were in the band
and that was prior to having a record
deal is that right
that was right when we had gotten signed
actually we recorded
in late 98 early 99
album came out in 99 so i joined in 97
and we basically we that's when we
really started writing
the core of what the the first album was
and what
people would consider like the classic
traps on that album that's when
we wrote surfacing we wrote spit it out
wait and bleed like all the ones that
people
really love and associate with that
first album really came after i joined
the band it was like this
kind of spur of creativity that really
just kind of came
and and really is what got a sign
because now here comes these labels
who have passed on the band before now
they're seeing us
a new lineup a new look new songs and
they finally go
ah okay we get this this this could
actually
work and that's when we got signed we
actually been we were technically signed
to sony for about five seconds
until they saw us live and saw
nuts we were and they killed our deal
dude
like they for real killed our deal like
it was the funniest thing
i've ever seen and we thought we were
done but then ross
robinson said well screw it if nobody
else
signs you then i'll sign you to my
imprint
and i will produce you and put you out
to be regardless
the first the first record deal was with
road runner
right well yeah well they are who
eventually came in and then signed us
for real but
i mean we had a record deal with sony
that then they pulled on us because they
freaked out they were like terrified of
it i mean dude that makes no sense to me
because like
in watching youtube videos about
slipknot
like i was struck by like you know
one of these like huge outdoor festivals
and just the mosh pit with the people
bouncing up and down it was just like
i don't remember seeing footage of a of
a band performing with
that much kind of [ __ ] crazy energy
you know at that scale
you know and so for sony to see that and
and
not want to be a part of it and that's
just uh it blew it an air
yeah are you cool talking about sobriety
yeah man absolutely curious on what your
drug of choice was because i
read that you were doing math at some
time
well when i was a kid yeah i was when i
was a kid i was a speed freak
um i did coke it did math i did all that
stuff
um but as i got i quit all that when i
was a teenager because i i od twice when
i was a teenager before i was
16. yeah um to quit all that
i got older i got more into booze
honestly because it was just easy you
know and my
personality is such that i never drank
to chill i just drank to just
get [ __ ] up you know so it was
you know it was easy to just stay
medicated
for you know especially doing what i do
and to just
you know just continue that and i just i
found myself becoming
very very unavailable in my own life man
you know and
when you're a father uh you know at the
time i was
married a long time ago and i
just kind of i just decided i was like
man i got to figure this out
or you know this is going to go
a a direction that i don't want it to go
you know so
it took a long time to kind of figure
out who i was and be comfortable with it
again man you know
so when you guys were getting [ __ ] up
what was on the slipknot rider when you
guys were just going there [ __ ]
oh dude i don't even know if this was on
the rider but we just had it at all
times we had at least
nine bottles of jack at any at
every show um we had crown royal
we had jaeger there was like some
some people drank vodka um
guys would have uh guys would have drugs
brought
uh which i never saw because that by
that time i was just a
you know just an alcoholic um
yeah man there was i mean there was a a
lot of crazy [ __ ]
and so you guys would go on waking up on
a pool table
like in just you know just waking i'm
like
in a bar like i was like i was like how
the [ __ ] did i get
here i was miles away from the gig i
have no idea
yeah but how about how about the story
about you waking up in a [ __ ]
trash can or a [ __ ] dumpster
that might have been a kind of sensitive
question that i just asked corey right
there
but i'm about to address something
really sensitive with you guys
because the people from blue chew
reached out to me about trying
their blue chew tablets which contain
the same active ingredient
as both viagra and cialis except
theirs are chewable and cost a fraction
of the price
and at first i thought you know what i
don't suffer from erectile dysfunction
i've never really had any problems
getting boners but maybe this will be
fun
and so with an open mind i decided to
try it and let me tell you how simple
that was
you just go online to bluechew.com and
consult with one of their medical
providers
there's no awkward visit to a doctor's
office it all happens right online
at bluetooth.com and once you're
approved your bluetooth tablets show up
in a matter of days in the mail
and i'll tell you when mine showed up i
was kind of excited about it
i told looks i said hey babe i'm gonna
do the bluetooth thing and so i chewed
one up swallowed it
waited for about a half an hour got in
bed with likes and i'm gonna tell you i
can report
that i had an obnoxiously strong
boner it was a lot of fun i would dare
say a blast
we really did have a blast and i
couldn't wait to do it again
and i did and it was just as fun the
second time
and i really honestly want you to try it
because
it's that fun and you can get a whole
month
supply completely for free all you gotta
pay is five bucks for shipping
if you go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code stevo
so you have absolutely nothing to lose
you're gonna get a whole month's supply
completely for free you just have to pay
the five dollars for shipping
if you go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code stevo
so with nothing to lose enjoy yourself
with bluetooth tablets because i'm
telling you i
really really did and i'm going to keep
using them because it's
fun all right so now let's talk about
being in dumpsters
that's what i was wearing right yeah
that was after i had od
yeah i uh and i think what happened was
i
i the last thing i remember was i was at
a party this is when i was living in
waterloo
iowa i was at a party uh blacked out
we were all just kind of doing you know
just whatever was there
i think i like my heart stopped
something happened and my friend well my
friends
threw me away
i think that's what yeah i think that's
what happened that's the kind of city
that that
city is anyway but like when you wait
when you come to
i was covered in my own blood um i kind
of i pulled myself out of the dumpster i
had no shoes on
and i was like strike like
because there's that moment where you're
like you don't really remember how you
got there
and i had to walk dude i was 12 miles
away from my house
geez yeah i walked all the way back
and as i was walking i was like it was
starting to kind of come to me
and within a week i moved out of
waterloo i moved to
live with my grandmother in des moines
which
and then there you did were ever see
those guys after that or talked to them
about it no i didn't want it
yeah at that point i was like well if
i'm dead to them they're dead to me
yeah jesus christ yeah it's very pretty
heavy but then
what about like that little possibility
that like
there was some perfectly good
explanation for why you ended up in the
trash can and they didn't throw you away
maybe i mean
i mean that's a good question dude i
this day i was like
i just kind of was just like you know
what i should probably shouldn't ever go
back
to that life again you know i kind of
cut it off but that's a good question it
never even occurred to me but
maybe there was another just like a
perfectly innocent
there's not a lot of perfectly innocent
or good reasons to end up
like it was it a trash can or a dumpster
it was a dumpster
yeah it was a dumpster yeah that puts
you right up there with mickey six
he the same thing happened to him in uh
london in
uh february of 1986.
what happened he got he [ __ ] woke up
in a dumpster he went and [ __ ] scored
[ __ ] od and they're like [ __ ] this
dude the guy's dead throw him in
have the same deal oh [ __ ] yeah oh man
and then and then he wrote a tune about
it called [ __ ] uh dancing on glass
glass yeah some of the girls girls girls
albums yeah dude [ __ ]
i love motley crew man how long did
how long did it take you to get sober
until after that point well he said that
was when he was a teenager
so so now 11 years ago
yeah 2010. oh [ __ ] so you got sober
right after paul gray died
is that right i got yeah yeah i um
because i had i had quit drinking and i
started again
and then when paulie died i
uh it was kind of it was kind of weird
like
i was drinking to
kind of deaden the pain
but then physically it was hurting me
and it which made it really easy for me
to quit you know so i i i quit about a
month
after he passed i'm sorry who's paul
gray
he's one of the founding members of
slipknot he was a bassist
and by all accounts the most
down-to-earth guy
uh nicest guy didn't consider himself a
rock star
but you know ultimately succumbed to the
substance abuse
and died of an overdose man what was
that last day of
what was that last day of using like for
you it was
it was weird man like i was kind of
heading that way anyway
and i was on the uh
i was on this uh tour with stone sour
and we were at this kind of like after
show party
and i'm not a beer drinker but i was
that's all they had so i was just kind
of like tipping a couple of becks back
and i woke up the next day and i felt
awful
like just when i i had two beers
and i i had a hangover that felt like i
drank three bottles of whiskey
and it just for some reason it that was
like
the moment where i was just like you
know what i think this is it
this is it this is it i'm not getting
anything out of this anymore
like there's no pleasure in it there's
no
party in it there's nothing that i'm
getting from it except
pain i was like why do i keep doing this
so and that
between that and the fact that i just
lost my brother
to a you know who who he fought it his
whole life
like he would he would go to he would go
to treatment
he would come out and he would fight
with his entire
will and it was just too much he just
kept going back to it man
and but that that was it
for me i was just like i just i can't i
can't do it
so did that did it start with you going
going into treatment or you just did it
on your own
no i just i yeah i dry dried it i
dropped it
i've always done that i've actually
that's how i quit drugs as well i just
you know you deal with the dts for a few
days and then that's it i did the same
thing with
smoking i i just i just there's
something in my brain that just goes
you're done and i just so quick so you
did the dry thing
for for a while and then were you like
wow dude like maybe i should
get some support and join the fellowship
that's great
i'm not i'm not in the program but all
of my friends are in the program
so when i hang out with my friends it's
almost like i'm in a
de facto meeting to begin with and when
you talk
uh yeah so it's so it's weird and they
all
have known everything that i'd gone
through everything
they were all friends with all of my
friends and
it's it's almost like being in the
program but not you know
right i mean my uh
sort of take on it is that i mean for me
i just
don't even want to experiment with what
happens in me trying to stay sober by
myself because i'm a [ __ ] dead duck
but the way that you described having
been on you know meth and coke and just
put it down
and then like only alcohol you know like
some people can do it and evidently
you're uh somebody you can pull it so
[ __ ] right on it's a weird switch man
it's thank you
i mean and i'd still to this day don't
know why but it's also
i've i've experienced that in my life as
well
like with relationships with people who
were clearly not good for me i just
once i kind of figured that out i'm just
like you're done and i cut people
out you know i just i've never
overstayed my welcome with anyone
well i can't say been one but i was
married to her and that doesn't count
and uh but yeah i mean it's just
it's weird man i uh i guess it's the
blessing
um i wish it would have you know kind of
kicked in
quicker but at the same time i wouldn't
be where i'm at now
if i have gone through what i have you
know
so i never look at anything with regret
i always look at it from the standpoint
of
i'm going to learn from everything i've
been through and i'm going to write
about
it and if people if it helps anybody
then so be it
you mentioned stone sour and uh
the you got a new album with stone sour
is that right
no actually i just put on my first solo
album right okay
you were in stone sour before slipknot
yeah you did the first three albums with
slipknot
and then i was like okay we guys we need
to take a break from each other so you
went back to stone sour at that point
everybody kind of did side projects
yeah i mean yeah that was that was kind
of kind of it
the reason i put stone sour back
together was because
i was feeling left out
of the music writing process like i
wrote i wrote all the lyrics
but when i was doing stone sour i wrote
a lot more of the music
and it was it's because that music
doesn't sound anything like slipknot you
know so that was
one of the things that i was really good
at was writing that sort of music
with slipknot it's so intricate and so
different of course it makes more sense
that they would write
more of the music but for me i was there
was a part of me that wasn't feeling
fulfilled in that side of it which is
one of the reasons why
i put stone sour back together was to
kind of feel
like i was contributing a little more on
both fronts you know so i kind of
juggled both for the last what 15 years
right going from slipknot back to stone
sour
performing without the mask was there
any sort of like nakedness or anything
to like
get used to or was it just like getting
back on a bike i realized i
gained 60 pounds really 60.
oh my god yeah google fat corey taylor
and
so many pictures come up from that tour
dude i was like well i mean
and i was at the at the time i was still
drinking
so i kind of had the the whiskey bloat
going on but i
maybe just because i was drunk all the
time i just thought i was so hot
and i wasn't i mean i i looked like a
mixture between
meatloaf and jim morrison like it was a
weird
like fat jim morrison you know like
but i but i thought i was still
young corey and skinny and whatever so
i'm like up on stage and i'm
it's it's hard to look at let's put it
that way but but i will say
it was it was fun to kind of go back out
and rediscover myself in a weird way you
know and be like you know i could
you know i could do this without without
a mask you know and that's kind of what
made me feel like okay
the mask is really for slipknot you know
but if i'm just kind of playing music i
don't need the mask i can just
be mean and go out there and entertain
and do whatever
so it helped me kind of feel like i
wasn't
cutting myself off from the world and
just doing things that were
flip not centric that makes sense sure
when you were in stone sour before
slip knot like that the band hadn't
really like reached
like either sort of stardom
no no it was i mean we were just kind of
a i don't want to say
a basic rock band i mean we were a lot
of fun like a lot of people loved coming
and seeing us
it was weird because it was stone sour
and slipknot were like the two biggest
bands in
in town and it was almost like
at the time i was the
the best singer in des moines and they
were the the bigger band
in des moines and they wanted that extra
the extra tool that extra bullet and the
gun i'm not really sure
you're saying slipknot what's that
you're saying slipknot did
yeah yeah yeah slipknot did but then
you i i saw that uh you were at
slipknot's very first show
in the audience and you were like [ __ ]
i'm gonna be the singer of this band
yeah and i've never had that feeling
before dude i mean i would have
if they hadn't asked me to join i would
have done
stone sour till the cows come home i
would have eventually
done something that would have gotten
the attention of whatever because we
were
shopping just like everybody else in des
moines
watched that first show and i was right
in front dude i mean
they came through the audience scared
the hell out of it
everybody dude because they're full mask
they're in like
they weren't wearing the coveralls yet
but they were just in this crate these
crazy outfits
and they opened with i want to say it
was like
three minutes of just noise and blast
beats and just i mean it was like being
in a [ __ ] melvins concert i was just
like
i can't believe it it was so gnarly
and i just for some reason i was so
attracted to it
and still like drawn in by it
i i just i just was like i'm gonna be
the singer in this band
someday and i've never [ __ ] had that
thought in a million years for anybody
else and
a year later they asked me i just it's
crazy man
that's killer man did uh stone sour have
a record deal before
you got into slipknot no no that that
definitely helped being in slipknot
right so at the same time
we sounded different enough that we were
able to and we
we wanted to differentiate ourselves
right away
you know which is one of the reasons why
we never did any
like slipknot music on stage we never
did
anything except our own stuff
you know and i think as time went by
that helped us
kind of become our own band you know i
mean we were
always going to be in the shadow of
slipknot anything i do is going to be in
the shadow of that sure
all i can do is try to you know get
a couple of rays of light to kind of pop
here and there but
you know it's a good problem to have
dude you know it could be work
you know it could be [ __ ] way worse
right
like six a.m you know right
exactly yeah those guys can go and do
their thing
and it rules but i mean it's always
going to be in the shadow of motley
and it's a good problem to have man it
means that you made your mark
in musical history and so many people
love you for that
that no matter what they're they're
gonna give you a chance
on this other thing you know it's really
good yeah
[ __ ] right on what's 6am like a cover
band 6am
6am is nikki sixx's
other band yeah talking about uh motley
crew are there other bands you
like what are the other bands you grew
up listening to and is there anything in
there that would surprise us or surprise
a slipknot fan
i heard you tell larry kings that you
would love sinatra
yeah man yeah i mean i love jazz i'm a
i'm a jazz guy yeah um i listen to
it's weird ever since i was a kid i've
really just kind of listened
to whatever i want i was never one of
these kids that
kind of stuck with one genre i was
always the weird kid in every
group that i was that listened to
everything you know
i always caught [ __ ] from all my friends
because of the music that i listened to
so i would listen to i would listen to
slayer i'd listen to cinderella
i would listen to you know
the ghetto boys all right i was i was
like i just liked what i liked man
you know and i never made any qualms
about it you know as i got older i
really
started to kind of explore more of like
um
like the older hardcore stuff um i was
always really into like the 70s punk
scene
um but as i got as i got older i i
started kind of going backwards even
further and getting
like swing music jazz um
especially what they called bebop but
today would have been the progenitors
for
experimental jazz you know which would
you know gillespie
parker uh coltrane like all those that
really kind of took soloing
to a different level instead of you know
playing for the song
you played for the performance you know
so that kind of drew me into more of the
the music side of it um but then sinatra
man
i mean a song is a song right i mean
but when sinatra sings it's totally
different what got me into sinatra
what's his cover
of um
what is it uh something which is a uh
the beatles song
something something in the way she moves
he did a cover of that and i it tripped
me out
hard because he never liked rock and
roll but he loved
that song and i just
loved the way that he took it and really
just kind of made it his own
you know and that made me go back and
listen to everything
that he ever did and i just to this day
it's just he's
he's phenomenal is that hat you're
wearing a sinatra style hat
no i started wearing fedoras when i was
a kid because of freddy krueger
oh i love it thank god
but you know like a lot of bands they
got like they have their heyday
and then they're like it just sort of
they're around but it's not their heyday
and the thing is that with slipknot you
guys were
to put burst on the scene like 2001 like
2003 you're [ __ ]
completely like on fire taking over
but then you just had in 2019
like the the biggest [ __ ] year ever
right like i mean
so was there an early heyday and then
like a rebirth were you guys just
[ __ ] huge the whole time
but how did 2000 how did 2019
shape up to be such a huge year for you
guys it's really weird man
because everybody every time we put an
album out
all of these people try to write us off
like
like it's like oh it's you know it's
this it's this year and
people still pretend to care about
slipknot and all this [ __ ]
and yet our last three albums debuted
number one
wow so it's not just 2019. like you guys
just been killing
it the whole time yeah so it's
i think it's because we go away for a
while
and then we come back you know like we
go we we
we're not one of those fans that
overstays its welcome
we come out and we go gangbusters for
like
a year and a half two years and then we
split and we let people
miss us man we remind people of why
they loved listening to us in the first
place and
with every album we try to give people
something different
we try to give them we give them this
the slipknot stuff that
you know that they expect but we also
whip some
some some different stuff on it we're
constantly trying to push the boundaries
of
where we go music music wise and i think
because of that
people have gotten to the point where
they never know
what to expect with our album they know
they're going to get new masks they know
they're going to get new outfits
they're going to get new art but they
never know
musically where we're going to go which
is rad man so
it's it's kind of it's kind of cool you
know i mean it's
you know it's been 22 years since our
first album
and people are like freaking out because
i i mentioned
in in an interview that we were working
on new music
and the world went ape [ __ ] yeah which
is
so that dude that it's
everything you want to hope for when
you're
like you know like it's just like
we we just get to do it all and it's i
can't be happier for the fan base that
we have
for the opportunities that we've had for
the luck that we've had
obviously we've had some some rough
times but you know i mean
we're still here man and that's that's
got to say something
[ __ ] yeah what what's the process of
coming up with a new mask look like do
you have like uh
like a special effects guy that like
sometimes man i mean sometimes we have
like a vision in our head like clown is
really good at it because he's an
artist so he'll kind of go somewhere
gnarly and be like okay i've got this
image and then we'll have
you know outside people kind of help us
create it but then there's sometimes
where you're just like
you know what i don't have a real vision
but i have an idea and you talk through
it
with you know like a visual app like a
visual arts guy or you know like a
visual effects guy
and they will create it for you and then
you look at it and you go i like this
change this and blah blah blah blah you
whittle it down
until you get to something that's really
rad you know
my new mask is going to [ __ ] scare
kids
so gnarly dude it's really
uncomfortable it freaked my wife out she
won't look at it and she
loves loves crazy [ __ ] like that
she's just like that's really bothering
me you put that picture away and i'm
like yeah this one and she just
couldn't that's so that's the one that's
not the process
that you went through with the uh when
they had to go through the
cover right right i mean for like
prosthetics
like uh when they turn us all into old
men for jackass
you go and you make like a plaster cast
mold of your head
it's not allowed you know you know the
feeling so you get molded every time you
do a new one
oh yeah oh my god because you were ready
to freak out
i couldn't do it there's no way it's a
claustrophobic [ __ ]
thing dude oh dude i fall asleep
[Laughter]
i told you there's something wrong with
me but i mean it's like for real like
you just
i've seriously fallen asleep before
where i'm just you know they have to
kind of give me a nudge because if i go
down like that i'm going to ruin them
because they took it off steve he was
like i almost lost it in there dude like
two more minutes you know like it's
tough man especially the first time when
we did it for
the jackass the movie my nose was all
blocked up with cocaine
all you can breathe through your [ __ ]
nose i could barely breathe through it
because there was so much [ __ ] blow
in there i was [ __ ] like not okay
wow i guess i'm glad that i waited
you know yeah i stopped doing bloating
yeah no kidding i mean people don't
realize how much you go through just to
get that mask
i think it's just the math that you go
on but it's a process
pretty much so yeah i know and
completely changing the look that had to
have been [ __ ] scary man like
where you're like oh okay now i'm gonna
trash this
this look that that uh it was the first
one with the one that all the dreads and
stuff
yeah yeah yeah and then and then you
come back
well with the first my my mask the first
two albums were very
similar like the the iowa mask was
essentially the same kind of vibe
but i had changed the the uh the
aesthetic a little bit still had the
dreads
it was the original dread i kept those
but then we got to volume three and i
just went man you know what i want to
change this up and
some of the guys in the band had changed
theirs completely
on iowa and i was like well they can get
away with it
you know i'm gonna try something
different i did what was called
what we called the the the the football
mask
because it it was kind of cut like this
and then it had um
that quite the quiet riot sticks oh yeah
exactly yeah
um and once that worked
i knew that i could go and just
and do whatever you know once you get
past that first
initial risk i just knew in my heart
that i needed to
once you get past that man that's
[ __ ] sky's the limit you just go
run with it you know dad that's crazy so
what was the motivation to
to do a solo album i've been trying you
know i've been
honestly talking about doing it for a
long time
but it just didn't make any sense
because i had two band i had two
great bands um i had you know i had
opportunities to kind of do
you know guest spots with a million
different people so that
i was just like you know what i just it
just doesn't make any sense to do a solo
album right now because i'm
i basically get to do any type of music
i want
so right now just doesn't make any sense
the reason i did it now
was because i was i was putting stone
sour kind of on hiatus anyway
because i wanted to do something even
more different
and the whole reason i did the solo
album is because i had all of these
songs that i had written
that didn't work with either band you
know and
i had tried to actually give these songs
to other people
and they just it just didn't vibe with
it or they didn't want it or whatever
and i just said man these are [ __ ]
great songs
i'm just going to put it out myself you
know did you put it out yourself or did
you
do it with warner oh it's still on it's
still on road runner
oh [ __ ] but the hardest name is corey
taylor
we're still on we're still signed a road
runner
under the warner umbrella yeah yeah
they were bought by atlantic
and the atlantic is owned by warner so
it's all kind of okay
because i just noticed that like every
single music video that you have on
youtube for slipknot
has a gigantic warner logo on there
which is
you know which is weird because
technically we're not a warner band
yeah they just happened to own us it's
really
sad what happened to roadrunner man like
they were the biggest
metal label on the planet for the
longest
longest time and it seemed like
the powers that be just they were
independent like they weren't owned by
anybody they were like alternative
tentacles
right basically yeah but they were
massive they were massive worldwide they
had offices in
every country they had the biggest
bands in metal and
with one fell swoop they sold all the
rights
they became owned by a certain label
and within three years that label
fired everyone who had been working
there
for 20 years like they fight like they
fired almost everyone down to the point
where
they had to close all of the offices in
like all of these
countries i mean it was it was crazy
dude these were people i had worked with
my entire career
right but that's what happens when you
sell the [ __ ]
company trust me we all sat around going
[ __ ] man this is the end of an era right
yeah i mean they sell the company so
that's like you know what do you do when
you buy something you do whatever the
[ __ ] you want with it so it's
understandable
and as far as closing down all the
offices around the world like
you know probably looking at it and
consolidating probably made financial
sense you know
like let's not pay rent if you look at
the
impact that road runner records had
no doubt it's insane so to go from that
high
to then boom i mean it it shocked all of
us
like we were just like whoa dude right
and i was making a stone sour album and
like everyone i was working with
just got wiped out now we just went
um i mean we didn't have anybody to work
with what the [ __ ] just
happened i was crazy so i wonder what
they need to sell for what was going on
you know like
right sounds like they that is a good
opportunity yeah
corey what'd you do with your first
major paycheck that came in
i love knowing that you know like you
get your first paycheck and you're like
[ __ ] what do you spend it on you know
what i bought
i went at like i uh the first time i
really spent a [ __ ] ton of money on
myself
this is so sad this tells you how white
trash i am
okay are you ready for this yeah i
walked in to a best buy i walked into a
best buy and i bought ten
thousand dollars worth of dvds this is
no
i still have them they
could even print me out a receipt they
had to give me a computer
printout of everything that i bought
well like it was so [ __ ] low rent
dude it was
[ __ ] shopping carts and all of my
friends before i knew
they were like you want this one i was
like
[Applause]
so so i love that you like the original
oh i did i did the same [ __ ] thing
except more like with music
cds you know like i would you know
like but i don't remember that being
like the first the first thing
you've never asked me this i don't think
and you're the first thing the big
expensive thing that i bought i just
think i [ __ ]
i don't remember it i like bought a big
fridge and a lot of booze
i mean i would go on some crazy grocery
yeah once i had an apartment
okay you get your first not not not
jackass one
but like maybe then where you made the
most and you're like [ __ ] dude
i mean i don't know i mean i ended up
buying a rolex
in 2003. the rolex
yeah i mean dude it's kind of
embarrassing like yeah that's cool
i mean whenever i had a roll like i
ended up losing it in the pcp blackout
i literally blacked out on bcp i have no
id for all i know i gave it away
no idea yeah if anybody listening has
steve's first rolex
maybe just he'll sign it or something i
think i think
somebody knows what the [ __ ] happened to
somebody somebody else
i think i know you think you know i i
suspect i suspect that i know but uh
in any case so um so you got the the
the new solo album yeah and uh
are you going out on tour behind the
solo album
yeah actually we just i think we were
the first
to announce uh an actual practical
social distancing tour
okay we're actually gonna do um uh it
starts in may
starts made 18th or 17th i can't
remember we added a date
um and it runs till mid or end of
june and all but five of the shows have
sold out already
you know i bet i bet that whether while
you know
when come may come june i bet that they
start putting more tickets on sale
because
like they might i mean we we
we we got it down we sectioned it off so
it's like it's only 10 to 25
capacity um everything is social
distance
it's uh you can buy tickets in pods
and anybody in that pod you can stay in
that pod you can take your masks off but
outside of that pod you have to leave
your mask on
and that's regardless of what whatever
state guidelines are going on but we're
going off of the actual
cdc it's so [ __ ] funny like the
coronavirus you have to wear a mask and
we're talking to the
[ __ ] front man
i remember when wearing a mask wasn't
cool
right how many people is that uh
what are you guys doing arenas what do
you guys do
what we're doing uh like bigger theaters
um there's a handful of like outdoor
amphitheaters that are kind of like
which is a little easier to do
so uh i know there's a there's a handful
of them that are over a thousand
um but that's scaled in a place that
would hold five
you know so it's like so it's so it's i
mean it's still to me
it's still a gig man i played a charity
gig last year for 12 people
and it was one of the best [ __ ]
nights of my life
they were sitting so far away from each
other
weird dude i was just like
what the [ __ ] are we doing here it was
so but i was so stoked
to be in front of an audience that i
didn't care man
and that right there was like that told
me
that it wasn't about the amount of
people it was
about the experience itself you know and
that's one of the reasons why i did this
i know a lot of people
have been putting it off and putting it
up and putting it off because they want
to play for the maximum amount of people
because they want to get paid the
maximum amount of money
but i was like [ __ ] that man like i'm
basically breaking even with this
and i don't care like i want to i want
to [ __ ] play these shows
because i want to have a good time you
know right who i've got
the my my wife's dance group is going to
open the thing and [ __ ] blow fire and
[ __ ] ariel and it's crazy [ __ ] it's
cool we're just bringing a [ __ ] big
rock and roll party to
every city you know how many cities are
you doing
oh may through june so 30.
i think it's like 25 25 there's a lot of
the places we're doing multiple nights
right okay killer is there um with like
slipknot has these legendary live shows
is there a
a country that just goes the hardest
dude
we have so many we bring out the the
crazy [ __ ] and
everybody for real like
one of the places that people kind of
warned us about
is like you know you're gonna you're
gonna be put off by their by their
you know the the the solemn quiet and
when politeness was japan and dude they
chased this down the street like he was
a [ __ ] beetle
for real and they they jumped the first
night we played dude
the place was apeshit and
we left we we couldn't even stop to take
our stuff
off we just ran right down and got in
this big cargo van
right the fans ran out the front
came right around the club and jumped on
the van
and they were shaking it like this and
we were all like this is it
this is how we die right here this is
insane
we're dying in japan and it was but then
they let us
like they finally let us go and we
all sat there and it was that weird
awkward like
that was kind of rad but we almost died
moment like it was like
to this day man we go there and they
absolutely give it up i mean it's crazy
so uh we don't need to promote the
the solo tour because it's already sold
out all but five shows
and if you wanna if you wanna figure out
which of those five shows aren't sold
out
or maybe if you're holding out hope that
the world's gonna open up enough that
more tickets go on sale
where do people go to buy the tickets to
your tour
oh uh you can go to my website
thecoreytaylor.com
uh there are links uh all over there you
can also go to notfest.com uh which is
uh
my management has links up there as well
um
if you know where any of the gigs are
you can probably go to those venues
websites
and access for tickets and whatnot um
it's yeah i mean it's uh i think there's
a good a good chance that they're gonna
like put more on sale i think i hope so
man i mean i'm getting
i'm getting my uh my uh
backs i'm getting my vacs next week and
uh they just opened it up in nevada
where uh anyone 16 and up can get
and get them we were kind of waiting on
that i might go ahead and
you know i didn't want to you know show
up to one of these places and be like
hey could i get something they're like
budgets
to do a road trip to las vegas you're in
nevada
yeah yeah i live in vegas actually oh
how about that dude [ __ ] cool man i
was just thinking man i wonder why we
didn't ask where he's at
um now you also said
that uh when i was on social media so
you've just given up social media
i've got people who run my [ __ ] for me
but
i much like booze and all that [ __ ] you
know i was
really really into it yeah you did i
[ __ ] had it
actually i talked to nick nicotine today
you know and uh and i was like yeah dude
like
i'm helplessly addicted to the
validation of [ __ ]
like like just ridiculously monitoring
the performance of my social media posts
and he's just like ah he's just laughing
and he eddie said uh he's like me too
but no he
he's he's good about it but he said he
said you know like
it does fall under like your your career
you know to like to see what works and
what doesn't work so you do need to
check it
but you know this is maybe like an hour
after the first hour is very telling you
want to check once after an hour
and then you want to check once on the
second day and once on the third day and
after
three days it's it's run its course and
i said dude that suggestion man that's
like [ __ ]
okay quit sugar it's terrifying you know
but i mean it's the same thing i got off
of it ten months ago i deactivated my
account
just because it was just too much and
then i got a thing saying oh my password
was compromised and i logged back on
and i and i to change my password and i
was looking at it and i'm like
what the [ __ ] i don't even want to go
back on you know like i'm like i'm
thinking about just deleting the whole
thing because it doesn't make
it doesn't make sense for me i mean i
think for you guys like you could
promote your tour you can do this but
like
every cool photo that i've taken i've
sent to
like my family or my bros anyway i don't
need random
people dude i i don't want to [ __ ]
keep corey forever but i'd be like uh
speaking about books right like are you
a new york times bestselling author
multiple times over yeah man yeah
i've written four wow um yeah it's
uh like i said man
[ __ ] i'm pretty pretty stoked about a
lot of the stuff that i've been able to
do
because of slipknot you know because of
my career so um i've written four books
uh
uh the last one wiped me out though
right because it was all about politics
and it was right when trump won
and i like yeah i mean it was
nightmarish how exhausting that process
was
and i just said you know and i haven't
written another one since but you know
what's exhausting now
so what's exhausting now is focus what's
exactly sorry i just rudely interrupted
but
i said you know what's exhausting now is
trying to watch saturday night live
the trump's out of office they got
nothing and they got nothing
like all the ratings yeah i mean [ __ ]
dude like he really is like noticeably
like [ __ ] we're sorely missing donald
trump
is he still off twitter i'm dude he's
banned for life for everything
but now one of the other form another
one of your four books was just
the first one i did the first one i
wrote was about the seven deadly sins
and how to me those aren't sins they're
human traits
you know that's something that things
that we just all
experience and there are bigger and
worse things that could be looked at as
sin
so okay and it's just honestly it's just
a way for me to kind of dissipate and
then
uh kind of go up on tangents and tell
stories about all the weird [ __ ] that
i've done in my life
the second one was about the
supernatural yeah that's when i was
gonna ask about the spirits
yeah man yeah i uh you know i just
it's just something that i've had
experiences with my whole life
and not being a religious person or a
specifically
atheist right right very much so i it
was
it was me trying to figure out
something to to to explain it you know
because i
know everybody's explanations never made
any [ __ ] sense to
me so that was me trying to work out in
my own head
what this phenomena was and then just
kind of you know
and doing that has helped me in a lot of
really
you know cool ways you know like i don't
i don't really get
freaked out by the stuff anymore i just
i just kind of you know process it you
know you deal with it it's boring
because it's so weird
and it's it's frightening but because
it's so weird but once you get
to the point you've wrapped your head
around what it is you can process it you
can deal with it you know
and then the third just me bitching
because i'm an old man and i don't
understand the world
dude's so great dude i'm working on my
second book right now
and i don't know it's uh my personal
take on middle age
and and oh oh god right okay so
like sort of like life life lessons and
how to sort of help other people prepare
for
and make it through middle age self-help
author
i mean sort of it's it's a [ __ ] crazy
book
it's uh so um did you do your own
audiobooks did you
yeah and it's a [ __ ] boring process
like the worst it's the one thing that i
would
never ever want to do and it was my own
idea and i cursed myself to
this [ __ ] day about it like it's just
for like wiping my ass with four days of
my life
five hours at a time yeah oh no
is there a particular way that you'd
like to promote the books
like for me uh if you buy my books from
stevo.com
every copy is hand signed you know like
i ought to go so that's my way of kind
of
selling my own books yeah no i you know
what i
i just kind of you know go find it and
buy it where you can you know
like you know [ __ ] that they don't have
any cory taylor books in the airports
and they'll stalk them you know because
that's that was
how i knew i made it i found one book
in an airport and i went yes
[Laughter]
you know that was my thing des moines
airport somebody just left it there i i
love it
do you have a preferred way that people
can consume
the music from your three bands
uh i mean obviously i'm gonna say you
know the old school way you know buy the
album
you know look at the artwork read the
lyrics you know kind of do whatever but
i'm also
you know um
you know it's it's kind of weird it's
kind of hard because
in this day and age it's really hard to
know which
one which which ones of the [ __ ]
streaming services actually compensate
the artists that they're ripping off so
right i mean
the label people would probably know
it's more important for me to people
listen to the music right you know like
at this point i've kind of made
peace with the fact that their various
services were just kind of
screwing us and until the legislation is
actually enforced which they passed
under trump that they couldn't [ __ ]
believe they'll
keep you know charging is that at that
rate but
they've appealed that legislation i
don't think the appeals will actually go
through
they will raise the rates and musicians
will be able to make a
living off their recordings again all
right
oh yeah lots of people [ __ ] dower
[ __ ]
no not at all it's okay lars
dude i i remember everyone giving him so
much [ __ ]
because of that and he was so right yeah
[ __ ] levels dude it's scary and i i
wonder how many people
like look back and and eat a little pro
because of that you know
weird yeah i think he was pretty
unapologetic about it the whole time and
i don't think
he knew he knew he knew that this was
the direction we were going man
so right
is there anything else we can uh get the
word out about for you
um i'm not sure man just
everybody just use common sense and you
know in
the world right now everybody's excited
because
uh you know they're ruling out the
vaccination and numbers are going up
every day which is bad but we're also
seeing spikes
and infections and and you know cover
diagnosis
and it's it's
it should be noted that there is a
certain grace period
after you get vaccinated that you're
still
you know kind of open right the
the you know the variance and whatnot so
everybody just be careful man
wear a mask this is coming from a dude
who made his [ __ ] bones on it wear a
mask
be smart don't give a [ __ ] about
politics left right whatever
be smart about it man what a good guy i
ask him is there anything
you want to promote and he's promoting
life
saving lives i'm like no what do you
want to sell
having said that we're a mask when you
come see me on you know
i love it man well [ __ ] hey dude it's
been a real a real treat dude
and uh you know i um i i super
appreciate you
and uh i can't can't wait for i think
this is what this one's going to do real
well man
yeah this was really cool to get to talk
to dude yeah man
i appreciate it i'm glad i could do it
hell yeah brother all right man well
we'll sign off here dude and [ __ ] you
have a good one
all right guys ride wild man all right
did i tell you was that rock and roll or
what
man such a good time and uh for those of
you who stick around at the very end
it's always just
a real sense of gratitude that i have
for you
i want to tell you something especially
because at the end of the mark cuban
podcast a couple weeks ago
you know on the youtube version of
course you could see me trying to do
some kick flips here in our editing bay
and i saw some comments about people
saying man you should hang it up
stop skateboarding because you're really
struggling with it and
i just thought man you know what i'm not
gonna hang up [ __ ]
because i love skateboarding and i'm
gonna continue
to push harder i mean now in my 40s i
got to work a lot harder
but dude come on i'm not
[ __ ] stopping and just yesterday look
what i was up to at the barracks
for those of you watching man it's a
serious [ __ ] wall ride dude
and the video that i'm making to launch
my new pro model skateboard
like properly [ __ ] it's badass so yeah i
just wanted to give you guys
a little sneak peek right there cause
it's a big deal
i love you dudes thanks so much yeah
you